Donald Trump's former lawyer Jenna Ellis
getting in on it this is a horrific take
that the author didn't walk back just
said he's now getting harassed so
deleted it David Pacman you harassed
Christians and should apologize for this
offensive tweet targeting our sincere
Faith No I'm targeting anyone who says
thoughts and prayers and nothing else
Jenna Ellis says evil persists and we
don't represent prayer as a complete
Shield to The Perils of the Fallen World
but rather than through faith in Christ
we can accept salvation and live it I
mean it just you know religious Babel
now
Thessalonians tells us give me a break